Jack disinfectants into their bodies in
May I condemn the false choice between
preserving public health on our economy
I urge the administration to focus on
the basic public health measures like
testing that would enable us to sustain
our economic recovery Trump's response
he pushed for reopening without regard
to safety and called testing quote
frankly over reading this month I
outlined a path to reopen our country
safely and sustainably that provided
workers small businesses schools state
local governments the tools resources
and guidance that they would need from
proposal he set a cutoff date for
federal funding of testing sites in
several states and actually went to
court to take away health care for
twenty-two million people by trying to
get rid of Obamacare and now Donald
Trump is in retreat
remember back in March when I called and
he called we talked about the need to
act like we were at war with the virus
he called himself a wartime president
remember when he extorted exhorted the
nation to sacrifice together and quote
in the face of this inevitable and an
invisible enemy what happened now it's
almost July and it seems like our
wartime president has surrendered waved
the right fly what white flag left the
battlefield today we're facing a serious
threat and we have to meet it we have to
meet it as one country but the president
gives no direction and he pits us
against one another we can't continue
like this
half recovering and half getting worse
we can't continue half wore a mask and
half rejecting science we can't continue
half with a plan and half just hoping
for the best you know we won't defeat
this virus
with a piecemeal approach lifting
restrictions prematurely increasing the
volatility of the crisis raising the
likelihood of needing to reimpose
restrictions you know until our science
catches up to reality until we have
better treatment for those who become
infected and ultimately are safe proven
widely available vaccines we have to
continue to do all we can as the people
on the government to keep our fellow
Americans safe and healthy today I'm
releasing the plan for the steps I
believe Donald Trump should undertake
immediately to build on the roadmap I
released back in March that would have
saved lives that have been adopted it's
a plan to save lives in the months ahead
but once again I encourage him to adopt
this plan it's in the entirety this is
too important for politics first testing
testing testing more testing is not only
how you find more cases of coronavirus
mr. president it's how you stop the
corona virus cases testing followed by
rigorous contact tracing quarantine and
isolation protocols for those who've
been exposed people aren't waking lines
from miles and miles long in baking hot
cars for drive-through nasal swabs for
the fun of it they're doing it so they
can protect themselves but even more
importantly they know and they have this
mask on they're protecting others but
protecting others we know we're not
where we need to be in testing there are
still hospitals and nursing homes that
don't have access to the tests they need
testing is how we see what's happening
in communities all across the country
it's our eyes on the ground without that
testing we're flying blind
that's why it's so important to have
reliable access to testing everywhere we
need to increase federal support for
gesture that includes doubling the
number of drive-through testing sites
and keep increasing them until they're
no more lines we should create a
pandemic testing board to spearhead a
nationwide campaign so every worker
every worker is called back to the job
can have the confidence that they and
their fellow workers are not infected
you know experts agree that we need more
contact tracers to track the path of
this virus individual states like New
York and California already hiring and
training thousands of tracers but we
need to do more including hiring at
least 100,000 federally funded workers
to perform contact tracing and other
public health tasks and they should
begin to be trained now second every
single frontline worker should have the
personal protective equipment that they
need to be safe five months into this
crisis and their health care workers
still are forced to scramble for their
own supplies and have to reuse these
mass shift after shift hundreds hundreds
of health care workers have died from
Cova 19 and tens of thousands have
become infected it should be zero on
both counts for these health care
workers and they have the right
equipment you know how we this many
months into this and still still don't
have what we need that's why we have a
defense production act you know mr.
president usual Authority mr. president
use it this week scale up the production
of n95 mass you know the steps you've
taken so far haven't gotten the job done
mr. president fixed a shortage of PPE
for our health care workers before you
tee off another round of golf
we can't just look at where we are today
we're gonna do these masks and gloves
and face shields for the foreseeable
future and we need to be ready we know
more is coming
thirdly we should be laser focused on
treatments and vaccines we should be
leading a coordinated global approach on
the science not disregarding experts
while pushing dangerous and disapprove
drugs as if their treatments there's
been some progress towards treatment in
vaccines but the administration hasn't
been transparent about how they plan to
manufacture enough doses to make sure
there's equitable distribution to the
scale I hope they're doing it now I call
for a while ago they should providing
250 million dollars have a plan now
exactly how they're gonna distribute
this so every American has access when
and if the vaccines available they may
be doing it but we have no transparency
let us see mr. president the White House
should report weekly on this progress we
can't end up in the same scratching and
distribution problems that we hadn't
tested we need to make sure the
customers aren't being gouged by new
drug and therapies and prices when
they're developed we have to immediately
restore our relationship with the World
Health Organization for all its
shortcomings and missteps around copa90
this is why whu-oh was created it is
essential to coordinating the global
response during a pandemic and the
United States should be leading that
response as we had in the past : 19 will
likely worsen at the outset of flu
season this year so we need to put in
place measures now now to ensure the
seasonal flu vaccine can be ready
available and ministers safety to those
who need it under social and distancing
guidelines especially for seniors
fourthly
we need real plans real guidelines with
uniform nationwide standards help us
chart our economic reopening whatever
we've been doing now is not working
the state-by-state approach will only
produce confusion and slow any progress
you know you all reported the CDC
tried to clear guidelines about what
stages of reopening should look like the
administration delayed and scaled back
those plans we need clear evidence clear
evidence base steps that states can
adopt now both the standard must be met
in order to safely proceed with further
openings and the reposition of social
distancing roles when cases begin to
rise you know it's just not rocket
science we need to support schools and
child care programs so parents if and
when they can return to work are
confident that their children will be
safe and cared for you know we should be
holding and providing stickers a safe
for shoppers a certification to stores
that prove they're minimizing their
customers risk and exposure we
absolutely need to clear message from
the very top of our federal government
that everyone needs to wear a mask in
public period period wear a mask it's
not just about you it's about your
family
it's about your nation it's about your
neighbors it's about your colleagues
it's about keeping other people safe it
helps you yes but it's about keeping
other people safe it's a simple measure
there's also on the most effective ways
we can do the right thing it may be
inconvenient it may be uncomfortable but
it's the right thing to do as an
American
protect your co-workers and neighbors
and finally we need to protect the
populations most key risks our seniors
are black and brown populations Native
communities that are being hit the
hardest
vulnerable populations of the
pre-existing conditions know that this
continued growth and case numbers is
causing a lot of fear and anxiety people
especially older Americans and those are
those loved ones and nursing homes I get
calls all the time they're simply scared
they're frightened
this is nest aching a toll on the
physical health
it's an emotional cost as well we can't
expect vulnerable populations to
quarantine indefinitely without support
I want them to know that their health
and safety will be my responsibility if
I'm repressive and I will not abandon
you you know these are five fairly
straightforward steps they're going to
help defeat this pandemic and if you
suspect that a lot of these steps are
the same sorts of things I was talking
about a March when I released my first
Cova 19 response you'd be right it feels
like you're hearing the experts talk
about the same issues for months you'd
be right these have always been the
steps the government needed to put in
place to meet the threat statewide
lockdowns that so many Americans lived
under for months were intended to bias
time to get her act together instead of
using that time to prepare ourselves
Donald Trump squandered it now here we
are more than three months later we're
hardly better prepared than we were in
March infections are on the rise
the threat of massive spikes that
overwhelming capacity of our healthcare
system is on the horizon
Americans anxious and out of work are
fearful for their lives and their
livelihoods Donald Trump is doing next
to nothing about it mr. president
crisis of the real is real the crisis is
real and it's surging mr. president
your promises and predictions and
wishful thinking pulled out of thin air
are not only doing the country no good
make them losing the more faith in their
government America knows this crisis
isn't behind us even if you know they
see what's happening even if you refuse
to mr. president they know we need a
coordinated national plan we needed now
even though you don't mr. president and
won't do it you called yourself a
cheerleader we don't need a cheerleader
mr. president we need a president mr.
president a president who level of the
American people president tell us the
unvarnished truth president take
responsibility instead of always blaming
others president will listen to the
experts follow the science allow them to
speak president lean be an example for
the nation wear a mask keep your
distance
limit the size of crowds mr. president
this is not about you it's about the
health and well-being in the American
public
America people don't make enormous
sacrifices over the past four months so
they could just waste waste their time
and you can waste all the efforts they
have undertaken within midnight Rapids
and rantings and tweets
they don't make these sacrifices you can
ignore the science and turn responsible
steps like wearing masks into a
political statement and they certainly
didn't do it mr. president so you can
wash your hands and walk away from this
responsibility maybe there are times
this nation needs a cheerleader now is
not one of them America needs a
president whatever Trump does or does
not do
we can't know today with the state of
the Kovach 19th pandemic will be next
January but I'm almost certain I hope I
turned out to be wrong I'm almost
certainly it won't be over if I should
have the honor of being elected
president on the day I'm sworn in I'll
get right to work implementing all
aspects of the response that remain
undone I'll have more to say about my
day one Cova 19 agenda in the weeks to
come but my response will begin well
before I take the oath of office it will
start as soon as the election is decided
I'll be a president respects scientist
who won't censor their ability to speak
directly to the American people
I don't legally I immediately reach out
to dr. Anthony Fauci to ask him to
continue his incredible service to the
country and I'll have from day one ready
to go the best medical experts and
scientists to advise on our response
maybe most importantly I will listen to
them and let them speak freely and I'll
work with the governors and mayors of
both parties from every state territory
a tribe it's a simple proposition folks
we're all in this together we've got to
fight this together will emerge from
this stronger because we did it together
I'm gonna confidently can may god bless
you all and may God protect our troops
I'm happy to take questions if you have
it gave me a list how it recognizes
alexei p out there couldn't tell with
the mascot yesterday that president was
briefed as early as March of 2019 that
Russia had ordered or offered bounties
to the Taliban for the killing of US
soldiers you called his in action on
this issue a betrayal
so broadly what consequences do you
think the president should face for that
betrayal and specifically what do you
think Congress should do look first of
all Congress and the intelligence
committees and the Congress both parties
should demand to the facts this seems to
be a moving story as I was leaving I had
the television on as I put on my shirt
and I understand there's even some more
information that's come out today about
what was know one of two things this
president is talks about cognitive
capability nuns only be cognitively
aware of what's going on he either reads
and or gets briefed on important issues
and he forgets it or he doesn't think
it's necessary that he need to know it
but the fact is that at a minimum at a
minimum the discrepancy allegedly
between within the intelligence
community has reported some thought it
was more certain and other so it was
less certain that should be resolved the
president should have on day one said I
want you to come before me in the in the
Situation Room and lay out the
differences in discretion what who is
who's always saying what let's get to
the bottom of this number one number two
it's clear to me that and I don't know
whether he did he should have
immediately contacted our our Joint
Chiefs of Staff gotten them all on
room and sat and said okay what are we
doing to prevent this what are we doing
to prepare to deal with this if this is
happening how are we doing this what are
we doing thirdly he should at a minimum
have picked up the phone and said
Vladimir old buddy if any of this is
true and it doesn't cease immediately
you've got a big problem a big problem
and make it clear get to the bottom of
this it appears as though from what I
have and I don't have access to
classified information anymore but if
what I have heard over the last week and
the recent reporting that it was in the
PDB the presidential Daily Brief the
president's availabe for something I
read every single day is vice president
the president read it every day I was
briefed every morning before I got to
the White House and then again so the
idea that somehow he didn't know or
isn't being briefed it is a dereliction
of duty if that's the case and if he was
briefed and nothing was done about this
that's a dereliction of duty I guess the
best way for me to end this is I was
talking to Jill I'm my wife Jill and I
don't see her get outraged very often
he started asking something chi'lan what
would you have done if bob was still in
harm's way and this information came out
and the president but was my son who was
in I'm sorry I apologize who was served
in Iraq for a year was in the Army but
if he'd been Afghanistan what would you
do Joe what are those parents thinking
out there what are those sons and
daughters husbands and wives it's an
absolute dereliction of duty if any of
this is even remotely true so I think
the president's a lot to answer for and
should get the itches quickly quickly if
they're if these allegations are true
and he did nothing about any of this
then in fact I think the pratik the
public should unrelated to my running
conclude the dis man didn't fit to be
President on States of America I was
told by NBC Mike it's my great relief he
doesn't have to follow me every day
around the country on the campaign trail
you were still locked in a very
difficult nomination battle the polls
though today show you with a sizable
national lead a lead in a lot of the
states that are critical in the
electoral college
I wonder where do you think the race
stands at this moment what keeps you up
at night as you look ahead and can you
maintain this advantage without
campaigning in a traditional way
especially this fall when voters begin
to really tune in well you know I this
is the most unusual campaign I think in
modern history in that but I start off
with the premise Mike that I'm gonna
follow the docs orders not just for me
but for the country and that means that
I am NOT going to be holding rallies I
am NOT going to be for example you all
are here but thank a school is put those
circles around so we keep to a social
distancing everybody has masks on as
soon as I finish this I'll put my mask
back on and so it's all been almost all
been virtual although I have gone to
Houston I have gone into Pennsylvania I
have ganda I have travel but what I do I
get in make my case and leave take
questions and leave and and so but you
know me I'd much rather be out there
with people because that's where I get
the greatest feel I can get a sense of
what the by the look in their eyes by
the plaintiff voices that they have and
what they're concerned about
but notwithstanding that I have been
surprised
the irony is we probably reached more
people directly on one on one you all
particularly those of you who are with
the with television stations you all
know that when you're on your you
haven't
one-to-one conversation with a with with
someone out there because there's one
person to TV looking at I never quite
thought of it that way before but they
tell me 200 million people have watched
what I have done from home and the half
a dozen things we've gone out and done
and and so the irony is I think we're
probably communicating directly in
detail with more people than we would
have otherwise but I'd much rather be
doing it in person so far it remains to
be seen I don't want to jinx myself I
know the polling data is very good but I
think it's really early it's much too
early to make any judgment I think we
got a whole lot more work to do
I plan on laying out in detail my
economic plan is how we recover from
this plan on dealing with foreign public
working out in detail what I'm going to
do if I am elected president people know
what's coming so I know that answers
your question first have you requested a
classified briefing as you would be
entitled to as the nominee has the
administration offered you a classified
briefing and then they have not offered
a classified briefing and as this
proceeds I may very well do that I've
been talking to I have a significant
foreign policy staff as you know that
matter of fact dozens of them I so I had
a long meeting with my former national
security advisors former secretaries of
state etc and got him there read what
they've heard so far but if this if it
doesn't get cleared up quickly that I
will seek and ask if I can be briefed
lastly have you begun to prepare for
debates against President Trump I can
hardly wait all right over the weekend
Princeton decided to remove Woodrow
Wilson's name from their school and and
buildings due to his racist thinking
president Trump yesterday called that
decision incredible stupidity what do
you think about Princeton's decision and
the president's comments
and then more broadly as the nation is
in this moment of reckoning when it
comes to rates we're seeing the removal
of statues also the removal of names
from institutions and schools do you
think that this is the right approach to
come to terms with our nation's history
and its leaders what do you think when
you see the removal of some of these
statues well I think they're sort of
three categories I like one any
institution that chose a name and wants
to now jettison that name that's a
decision for them to make for whatever
reason they make it so I'm assuming the
board of trustees at Princeton
University made the judgment about the
Woodrow Wilson School I don't know but
it was made within the context of a
institution that chose that name and now
no longer wants to be associated with
that name and I think the president's
well secondly I think there are there's
a distinction between the as the former
mayor of New Orleans said the difference
between reminders and remembrances of
history and recovering from history and
so the idea of comparing whether or not
George Washington owned slaves or Thomas
Jefferson owned slaves and somebody who
was in rebellion to committing treason
running trying to take down a Union to
keep slavery I think there's a
distinction and so I think the idea of
bringing down I think all those
Confederate monuments to Confederate
soldiers and generals etcetera who
strongly supported secession and
maintains the maintenance of slavery and
going to World War two do it I think
those statues belong in museums they
don't belong in public places and I
think with regard to those statues that
are and monuments like the Jefferson
Memorial whatever I think there's an
obligation that the that the government
protect those monuments because they're
different than that's a remembrance
it is not a dealing with you know
revering
somebody who had that view they much
broader views they may have things in
the past that are now and then
distasteful but that's a judgment for
the console for example taking down
toppling Christopher Columbus statue or
George Washington statue or etc I think
that is something that is the government
has an opportunity and responsibility to
protect from happening on a subject you
have been doing these public events for
the past month which has put you in
contact with more people have you been
tested for coronavirus and if so how
frequently are you doing that no I have
not been protected I have not been
tested for the coronavirus for two
reasons one I have had no symptoms as my
mother would say knock on wood and
number two I haven't wanted to take
anybody else's place in the process but
the Secret Service they all get tested
there around my home and anyone who
comes into my home including staff a
comes and is tested to determine whether
they have the virus I expect when I'm
going to do so it doesn't look like I'm
you know moving in the front of the line
here is be tested relatively soon my
daughter has been tested she was in
Florida as a she's a social worker
working with the Boys and Girls Clubs
she came home and before she could come
home she's been tested twice so to make
sure she's clear and quarantined she's a
lizard Philadelphia but so but I haven't
yet I have not been tested yet yes I'm
sorry who was I supposed to do the next
name anybody who I got to make sure you
get to the new the Wilmington newspaper
here before I major I'll be dead
Thank You mr. vice president's good to
see you and I know we all hope that you
continue to do this through November as
often as possible so I will more I have
an opportunity I will do it two quick
questions one to follow up on Russia you
talk about what our president has done
but yesterday you said at a fundraiser
regarding Vladimir Putin quote I'll
confront Putin I'll strengthen NATO I'll
make clear to Putin that'll have a price
to pay for interference and our
democratic processes specifically can
you tell us what you would do to Putin
if this is true and in general for
what's happened in the past I can but I
will not but I will tell him here's the
deal the idea that Putin or any other
foreign leader can engage in attempting
to manipulate the presidential election
the idea that he continues his
activities in Central and Eastern Europe
that he's doing the idea that it can be
done without any consequences is not
going to happen if I'm president my
administration that ranges from
everything to making sure we go to the
United Nations Security Council all the
way to imposing sanctions that would be
commensurate with the action that he has
taken that is inappropriate but I have
had some very blunt straightforward
conversations with President Putin when
I was vice president before that and I
think one of the reasons why it appears
as though he doesn't want me to be
President he knows we'll have more
conversations Supreme Court president
says he's going to issue an updated list
of potential nominees to the court you
have said you would put a black woman on
the court should a spot open up but
there are groups calling for you to
release a list of specific names you'd
put on the court are you going to do
that one thing I hesitate to do is
follow anything the president does at
all because he usually does it all wrong
I have we are putting together a list of
a group of African American women who
are qualified and have the experience to
be in the court I am NOT going to
release that until we go further down
the line and vetting them as well and
just like a logical question is about
vice president I'm not releasing the
names of all the vice presidential
potential nominees there are a number of
women of color there are there are
Latino women there are Asian or cost the
board and we're just underway now and
the hard vet of going into the deep
background checks that take anywhere
from six to eight weeks to be done the
Committees of inform and that's underway
well early August III can't County you
August one but it will be in early
August before several weeks before the
convention I believe yes
Thank You mr. vice president this is a
two-parter just to follow up again on
Russia do you believe that if those
reports are true that Trump is guilty of
violating his oath of office and and on
your VP choice you've said that you want
your running mate to be ready on day one
to do the job do you think that someone
who does not have national security or
foreign policy experience can be ready
on day one yes and that depends look one
of the things you try to do i've talked
at length over the years with brought
with president obama about this you try
to find people who have a background and
an expertise that you may not have and
so one of the reasons President Obama
picked me is because I had considerable
experience in getting things done in the
Congress and secondly I had considerable
experience in foreign policy and
national security and although he had
clear views of what in fact he wanted to
do and what his stand with what his his
strategy was in terms of America's role
in the world he was looking for someone
who had day-to-day experience and knew a
lot of those world leaders and so I
think that although that's a helpful
thing to have it's not necessary because
I start off with that the two places I
still have some expertise are in both
those places in uniting the country in
the Congress and foreign policy and so
it is
almost all of the women I'm considering
have had some exposure to foreign policy
and national defense national defense
issues and security issues but that is
not a minimum requirement requirement is
that they have the intellectual capacity
as well as the temperament as well as
the leadership qualities that lend to
you everyone to believe that they would
be ready on day one to be President of
the United States of America with regard
to whether or not the president it
depends on exactly what he did and what
he knew but at a minimum at a minimum
either doesn't understand his job and is
having difficulty sitting down and being
able to read a report because a lot of
those reports come across that he says I
you know I didn't read it I didn't see
it I didn't know it I don't know how he
could not read and not see and not know
so many different things that have come
up over the last three years and so but
it is clearly a dereliction of duty and
it is clearly something that I think
everyone including my Republican friends
and my Republican opponents in the House
and Senate are worried about as well
Thanks all right where's where's the the
Wilmington the Delaware State News I
mean Delaware News Channel I should say
that's my hometown team I better call on
them so like other states Delaware your
home state seeing an increase in current
of iris cases do you have a message for
Delaware officials state and local
governments for how they've handled the
pandemic so far how they need to handle
it going forward well I think they
handle it pretty well so far
but now I think you're seeing the
governor make some adjustments because
there has been an uptick not tremendous
but there's been an uptick it was one of
the states that was I get briefed every
day by a group of leading Doc's around
the world
around the country of vivec Murphy and
and and doctor been anyway and so every
day I get a printout having the book
here of the states that are doing better
and doing worse up to now there has been
a decline and now it's opening up
slightly and I don't I have not spoken
to the governor today but my guess is
I'd only guess is that he's going to be
looking very closely what happens on the
Delaware Beaches now how that has
occurred and restaurants and bars I
don't know enough to know that though
the good news is that is flattened out
the bad news is there's a slight uptick
and I have not gone into the detail of
the governor ignores as I speak to him
not infrequently but a couple couple
times a month three four times a month
and so I I don't have any advice for me
because I don't know where it's popping
up thank you thank you I know I know I'm
so I tell them I'll be late just a
little bit okay all right I always get
in trouble on the last question but go
ahead the response to this pandemic has
become very politicized even wearing a
mask has become political if elected how
are you going to get Americans on the
same page and can your plan be
successful if they aren't well I think
the way to get it on the same page is to
I'm going to try to say this politely is
to lower the rhetoric based on division
stop appealing to the
the less healthy side of society instead
of for example when a golf cart goes by
yelling white supremacy and the
president tweets it out don't do things
like that bring the country together
we're giving a portion of the population
who has responded to the sort of race
baiting the president has engaged in any
sort of free pass and it generates
divisions and we're also talking about
it in terms of the president talks about
you know manhood and you know being
strong and you don't need the masks I
think we have to start appealing to the
better side of human nature by pointing
out that that mask is not so much to
protect me it's if I have an undiagnosed
I have it as to protect you against me
to protect other people and it's called
patriotism it's called responsibility
it's called making sure you look out for
the other person and we have spent too
much time if you notice the president
puts everything in terms of him and I'm
not being facetious
everything is him it's I don't think or
I don't take responsibility or I didn't
do that or I believe that I mean it's
not about I it's about us and I think
changing the tone of an administration
across the board allowing scientists to
speak mayn't making sure that people
understand the facts good bad and
indifferent and when a mistake is made
to say I made a mistake I was wrong
shouldn't have done it that way we
should do it this way I think all those
things change the atmosphere let me
conclude it by saying this and I'm
apologized it heard me say this before
the words of a president matter no
matter who the president is no matter
how responsible or irresponsible
the president a president whoever he or
she is can take us to war or bring peace
to have markets rise or fall appeal to
the seniors side of humanity or our to
our better angels it matters it really
matters and so I think it's about the
tone and I think it goes across the
board I know I'll conclude with this I
know that I was criticized legitimately
criticized during the primary during the
primaries by saying that I plan on
uniting the country bringing Democrats
and Republicans together we have to do
that if we can't do that we can't
function we have to bring the country
together and I think on this piece if in
fact we stand up and by the way you have
what don't hold me the numbers please
you can correct me on this but I think
something like 70 or 74 or 75 percent of
the American people think you should
wear masks the overwhelming number
people think we should take these
precautions and so on think we did [ __ ]
over more slowly well I think that you
know we should be talking to our better
angels and actually making people
indirectly feel guilty for not doing the
right thing
appeal to their better nature I know
that sounds almost idealistic
but it's not remind people you don't
wear this mask you end up hurting
someone or you get infected you take it
home to your child you could take it
home to your mother and your father and
your husband your wife you have a moral
obligation because it really is it
really is thank you guys I really do
have to go
I apologize I'm gonna get any real
trouble I'm not probably already in
trouble but thank you go ahead what's
the last C I'm sorry
good to see you at about mr. vice
president I'm a little confused about
the delineation about the destruction of
Monti miss you talk about the fathers of
this country Washington Jefferson is
worthy of preservation
our Confederate monuments worthy of
preservation should they be torn down in
the manner that they are being torn down
without without the vote of local
elected officials well I think it's very
different I think it's better if they're
taken down like they took the
Confederate flag off the Mississippi
flag that's the better way of doing it
but I can understand I can understand
the anger and anguish that people feel
by having for years and years then under
the statute robert e lee who if you're
an african-american so it's a difference
it's always better to do it peacefully
but there's a distinction between and
those those monuments and and iiii shift
responsibility and i'm not
I think the elected officials where
those statues are have a responsibility
to move put them in museums get them
down but don't expect if you have
sitting in front of you after all these
years and we finally finally are going
through another phase of maybe
responding to the systemic racism in
America and what we've seen happen is
don't be surprised if someone pulls down
a statue of Jefferson Davis it's better
than they do not but it's fundamentally
different than pulling down the statue
or going into the Lincoln Memorial and
trying to pull you know the Jefferson
Memorial then grabbing Jefferson ologies
dead it's not too quick to quickies will
you commit to three debates oh yes three
three yeah I got commit to it look I am
committed to following the debate the
the national debate group that sets up
these debates who they pick as the
moderators three of them it's been four
this way for a long time the first one
is a one-on-one debate with a moderator
the next one is it's a town meeting
setting the third one is a normal debate
again I commit to those I'm looking
forward to last last question real quick
some have speculated that you that you
are subject to some degree of cognitive
decline I'm 65 I don't have word
recollection that I used to have I
forget my train of thought from time to
time you got 12 years on me sir
art have you been tested for some degree
of cognitive decline I've been testing
on concentration look all you got to do
is watch me and I can hardly wait to
compare my cognitive capability to the
cognitive capability of the man I'm
running against thank you so much